[Music]
remember when these two cuties were a
thing Mila Kunis and Macaulay Culkin
well it didn't work out and now we know
who blew up the romance I had a horrible
breakup it a horrible horrible horrible
breakup I like my 20 oh and I'll be the
first to admit it
Mila is taking the blame for the
break-up that went down back in 2011 the
couple dated for eight years have you
forgiven yourself you know it's been so
long like I feel like enough times gone
by I think enough mutual friends have
you know been like everybody kind of
forgave everybody what went down yeah
okay so Mila never actually revealed
what she did but she had no problem
admitting how she first hooked up with
now-husband ashton kutcher the 34 year
old gave the details to her close friend
Dax Shepard on his podcast armchair
expert recalling the moment she and
Ashton reconnected at an award show
years after they start on that 70 show
this very tall very good-looking stature
of a man walk by silhouette what a
good-looking he turns around and I was
like look what happened to him it was
like oh he had the same version of like
oh that's not the same little girl that
I used to know then he decided to set me
up on a blind date with someone else and
then that guy didn't show up and that
was a night that he and I hooked up and
kissed him before remember I kissed him
for seven years
oh yeah the fireworks oh my god Jackson
I'll tell you this I while I was single
never spent the night at any guys house
this was the only time that I ever spent
the night at somebody's house Oh Neal
also admits that she Nash and were crazy
neurotic about keeping their
relationship a secret in the beginning
probably to a fault because she also
said she a lien Aidid so many of her
friends but at the end of the day they
have a beautiful family and everything
has worked out
[Music]